I haven't seen before
oh if you find me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you going to try for a different
life
[Music]
my connection to the arts is music I
grow singing in the church that's how we
communicate that's how we relay my first
memories the performance go back to when
I was in Pennsylvania growing up my
favorite thing was getting to be
theatrical to tell a story and I've
always brought that sort of narrative
element to my live shows I was just
obsessed with singing I was obsessed
with dancing but it started off with me
in the kitchen you know with with my
socks on trying to do the moonwalk and I
think that you need to choose something
that you're so obsessed with you just
want to do it all the time
I was cast in 1981 just before we opened
I snapped my Achilles tendon and I
thought that that was my history with
cats but it turns out not to me
when I first heard I was going to be in
cats incidentally I felt the pressure
this musical is timeless
I just remembered loving it so when cats
became a movie obviously I jumped at the
chance I think it could really only be
done by a director like Tom Hooper he
understands the spectacle of cats at the
center of this incredibly entertaining
comedic fantastical musical is a very
timely story about the importance of
inclusion and redemption I think it just
speaks really powerfully to everyone
there are so many emotions and we've got
to update it in ways that I think are
just so so so great I came right off of
a stadium tour and went right into
rehearsals from tomorrow I start to sing
my big number
directing cats is like directing a group
of world-class athletes he politely
twins the possibly the most famous
hip-hop danced Europe
and Frankie Hayward is such a fine you
know he's one of the best arts in the
world as principal of the Royal Ballet
my favorite part of ballet and dancing
is telling the story without words and
how you can say that with just your eyes
or your face or your body I think it's
amazing
we also lucky enough to have Andy blank
computer you choreographed Hamilton when
you see people that are at the top of
their game doing it you raise your bar
as well people coming together through
all different corners of entertainment
you have some of the best hip hop
dancers royal ballet some of the best
tappers in the world
everybody's working really long hours
the first thing every day and it's fun
the designer lesense oh my god what is
this a so spectacular it's just so much
fun to play in the scale of this film is
huge three or four times bigger for the
cat perspective it's a massive
undertaking I kind of Alice in
Wonderland experience
Tom's pairing them with a kind of level
of technology which I don't think has
ever been used before we've used digital
third technology to create the most
perfect covering affirm these are people
but they're cats and this is kind of
blowing my mind
there is nothing else like it this is a
moment for you to step into a world
that's completely designed to entertain
now I just was like really excited and
so honored to get to be a part of us
this film is an event
[Music]